hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the tournament of
peace that was held in Zagreb Vasily
when truth versus Liberty eternity piano
now who maybe don't know Nyssa Panem not
so long ago we covered a game where he
eliminated Cara Nakamura from the World
Cup it was a really an impressive game
with including a very early Queen
sacrifice in case you haven't seen that
game I will put a link to it in the
description below so do check it out
really really just awesome stuff and yes
it is the same tournament of Pisa where
you know Kawachi she defeated Bobby
Fischer in 1970 but the tournament
wasn't held for quite a quite a long
time and it was only started to be org
organized since last year I believe
since 2018 so really the game is just
the simply brilliant it's simple and
brilliant and it's even though chuck is
no longer in his prime I believe he's
the only player above 50 who's still in
the 2700 club well now after this
tournament I believe he's in the 2700
club until Islander reaches 50 and then
Anand will be the second person above 50
years of age that is in the 2700 club
but still just a very impressive game so
I do hope you enjoyed and the for those
of you who are interested in such things
I often mention when someone does
something about chest so who got the
Chilean artist again made a song at this
time it's about Khurana she is
accompanied by Anna Rudolph in song so
if any of you enjoy you know things like
that do check it out it will be the
first thing you will see in the
description below a link to the song
about Caruana
so I mean I don't know why they made a
song about Quran and maybe it's just you
know Carson who won the World Chess
Championship so he gets to be the world
champion no one more cycle so I guess
the Khurana gets the song or maybe
something like that but either way do
check it out I would be very interested
to see what you thought about it that
being said let's check out this very
nice game Chuckie with the white pieces
opens with c4 the English opening is on
the board with a 6 by mississippiana
Knight to c3 and d5 now
we've before and now c6 with Knight to
f3 and Knight to f6 now we transpose
into the semi Slav defense with III and
now a six at some point you will want to
push c5 so we want the B five point the
beef five squared to be not available
for tonight and also it will help out
with the advancement of the pawn to b5
with h3 by chucking in the now c5 the
early c5 with C characters on d5e
captures on d5 and probably an easy
panel when he was preparing for his game
against Chucky well saw that Chucky
already had this position on the board
it was in 2009 in the amber blindfold
tournament but here Chucky went to
Bishop to e2 and he lost a game to you
when but here he goes
pawn to be three want to be three is a
new move in the position and it is
already as a move seven that we have a
completely new game so probably oh well
not probably maybe it comes as a
surprise to me cPanel but maybe not we
have seek a person d4 Knight captures on
d4 and now Bishop to b4 developing with
tempo the knight is under attack so
Bishop to b2 defending and out Knight to
e4 attacking the pin piece so knight on
c3 is under attack weave Queen to c2
adding another defender and now any
soprano adds another attacker with Queen
to a5 adding a third attacker and here
Knight to e2 you can't go rook to see
110 another defender because then just
Queen captures an a2 since the knight is
pinned so that's why I chunky goes in
Knights the e2 but also I will just show
that a3 is also possible even though it
seems like you're losing a piece but
you're not after Bishop captures and c3
membership characters Queen captures
with Czech Queen captures Knight
captures yes you've lost the piece but
rook c1 regains a piece because the
Knights under attack if you move the
knight you lose the bishop with check
and then the rook as well so it is
possible but Knight to e2 Chucky not
eager to trade all this many pieces all
that early although it will sometime
some what to delay development you know
you still have to get the night away you
get the bishop ended again maybe if you
want to castle and so on sony cpanel
castles now he's
castle to safety Iraqi skiing is still
in the center of the board so hopefully
now Mississippian can start his attack
with a three now Chucky says okay either
you go back or you know just give up the
bishop pair and it's interesting in
cPanel doesn't go back with Bishop to d6
you don't have to worry about this night
capturing anything since it would still
be pin so Bishop to d6 possible but he
prefers the bishop characters on c3 with
Knight captures and c3 and now Knight
back to f6 guarding the d5 pawn so you
know you don't have to worry about
something like b4 in the night
characters and also preparing d4 as like
we said Chucky's king is still in the
center of the board we have B for
pushing the Queen back Queen to c7 and
now Bishop to d3 preparing the castle
and here Nisa piano says nope d4 so
Chuckie Chuckie has to be very careful
here but luckily for him
there is one moved at a rhythm of all of
his problems and that's Knight to e4
which forces a Queen trade as if you if
you decline a Queen trade you move the
Queen somewhere easy 7 or E 5 doesn't
really matter you'll get a knight
captors and f6 Queen captures and now
you no longer have defense of the h7
pawn and once the King moves Bishop back
to e4 you've just won a pawn and what
White has much better development and
much better position you can't even
capture here as you would hang your
queen so any cpanel trades here
Queen captures and c2 but still chalky
gets the mess up nice be honest bone
structure Knight captures with check G
captures and only now Bishop captures
and c2 d captures and e3f captures and
III and rook to e8 so now if you look
the position the material on the board
is completely equal nice pan is
threatening to pick up the e3 pawn with
check but he has some issues with
developed developing the Queen side but
you know a move or two and everything is
well not at 5 obviously but everything
is perfectly fine however this position
is so much better for chalky
that he just shows us the way how to do
it so here your you know first
inclination might be something in the
lines of King be to maybe King e2 king
of
to defend the d3 point but Chucky says
activity above all and he just four
castles here brings the rook into the
attack and now when you see that this
rook is coming to f6 that the bishops
pair is incredibly strong now Anisa
panel really has to decide what to do
here he decides to grab the e3 pawn
although well yeah yeah grabbing that
point with so many undeveloped pieces
not so great but it's I mean it's still
the the engines second recommendation so
not not a blunder or anything
we have rook captures on f6 by trucky
and now Knight to d7 you don't want to
allow this rook rook h6 followed by
Bishop captures on h7 so first Knight to
d7 you develop a piece and now look to
h6 is met by knife to f8 so okay one
piece is in the game now there's only
Bishop to be developed but here Sharky
just goes rook to d1 in it's such a
strong move you cannot allow room today
if you allow roof to d8 it's just over
you pinned the knight the bishop is
covering the dark squares a bunch of
characters on edge summon is coming it's
just all over so here you have to
prevent rook to the eight but it's not
easy to prevent it for example if Bishop
to e6 just developing the bishop King f2
traps the rook that's that's the stuff
so the rook has no squares it's really
just just amazing how something like
this can happen so you cannot develop
the bishop you can go to f5 you can go
to g4 you can I go to d7 if d7 you can
just pick up the h7 phone if Knight
captures you no longer the guard that
the bishop on d7 so that's not gonna fly
so look back to e8 it's ugly but there's
no other way around it so Chuckie
develops and pushes opponent's pieces
all the way back so black still has
trouble developing we have rook to d5
now with ideas of not rook to g5 but
rather look the h5 adding a third
attacker to the h7 point so this is just
all beautiful stuff very simple and very
beautiful Bishop to e6 finally the
bishop is developed comes with an attack
on true but Bishop rook to h5 now going
after the h7 pawn and here we have look
to see eight just attacking the bishop
here so what do you do here well feel
free to pause the video even and try and
figure out what to do here while I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding such a beautiful
centralizing move with the bishop and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show if if Bishop captures an H seven
years of course that's obvious you do
win a oh you do win a pawn but after
Luke captures King f8 and even Bishop to
have six that threatens mate yeah black
still has King te 8 and now okay you're
better but you're only up upon and it's
still if black manages to Tradeworks its
bishops of opposite colors so it's it's
not gonna be much to go on
so instead after rook eat the ch-charlie
played Bishop the e4 congratulations to
everyone who found it now the b7 point
is a threat and if Bishop captures you
will just win material that's obvious so
rook 8 b8 but now Bishop to e5 yes you
now push the room back and okay
now you've left to the control of the C
1 square so black has enough time to you
know get the rooks out of harm's way
rook the c1 check King to h2 and rook
beat the CA but it still doesn't help
why black all that much you could
improve the position with the further
wood bishop to have sex but Chucky says
there's no need
Bishop captures and b7 you're gonna
eliminate these two points and now you
get to connected passed pawns with rook
to d8 getting the rook out of harm's way
wanting to go rogue d1 rook to h1 and
try to create some threats against the
White King Bishop characters on a6
we rook d2 d1 and now comes the Bishop
to e2 so in the future if rook tab III
check for example you can cover up with
Bishop to f3 rook the h1 check with King
to g3 and then now rook the b1 but it's
not a problem Bishop to f3 rook the b3
now threatening the a3 pawn but Bishop
to f6 now further improving the position
taking away some very important squares
from the black King and Chuck can always
just you know start marching up the
board with the King play Bishop to e4
capture on h7 and so on so we have night
the d7 attacking the bishop and the
bishop be back
well Bishop to e7 are not allowed
allowing the black King to escape
anywhere we have rook characters on a3
now you have to win back some material
otherwise if the pawn start marching it
is game over
and now rook captures on h7 we have
Bishop to f5 now attacking the rook now
of course if rook captures King captures
rook so here we have looked the h8 check
King to g7 and rook to b8 now and
believe it or not it was in this
position unmoved 39 that Olivia Theatre
in the cPanel resigned the game as there
is not well there is something to be
done but there is not much to be done
here point being that ok your Bishop is
under attack so you could move it Bishop
to e6 you still have to keep an eye on
the night and then now you get to rook
the g5 check point is if king h6 rook to
h8 is mate you don't have you don't have
a square with your king and if you don't
if you go to h7 it is better but it will
be still a very slow painful death for
example king f4 unpinning making sure
Bishop to g4 check is possible black
will prevent this would have 5 but now
you go rook h5 check King g7 and now b5
now you start advancing the pawn all of
these squares are already covered with
your pieces
Ruby 3 and now you just go rogue dita h8
threatening well threatening just mate
and here black doesn't have a good move
to prevent mate yes you can start giving
up material would look after Sun f3 but
that's just pointless you're already
down material and if something like this
then like we said it's just made rook
checks
that's check King g6 and Bishop to h5
will now be made very nice mate where
the bishop don't allow any squares for
the king so really amazing game really
really well yeah when I say simple I
mean simple 4/4 Chucky's
but it's like it's it's like a game
Capablanca would put in his book like as
an example on how to play good chess
this is what what I thought about this
game and it's really just weird that
nice panel gave up the bishop pair he
didn't retreat with Bishop to d6 why why
did he do it I have no idea but there is
he
how someone like Chucky punishes
something like this so like I said even
though chuck is no longer in his prime
when he has a good day he can still make
well almost a 2700 player seem
completely helpless like like he did
here so like I said if you if you
enjoyed the game do check out the link I
provided in the description below in the
cPanel vs Nakamura just an insane queen
sacrifice I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
and do check out the the rap song about
Khurana
also the first link you will see in the
description below so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Exopolitics consultants and Stefan
Crockett chuckles for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
in my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day